well
you're on the press may be getting tired
of seeing me all day today i'm
gonna see you again later too but uh i
hope my colleagues aren't tired to see
me they just got here
look what we're doing is at the uh
at the request a mutual request of us
getting together
getting uh leading republicans in the
senate together to see if we can work
out something
on a compromise on infrastructure
and and i know they're sincere about it
and so am i and what we're going to try
to do is figure out what we can
agree it constitutes infrastructure from
piece of our perspectives
and then see whether or not we're in a
position that uh
how uh how much we want to fund it above
the baseline
the baseline meaning what we spent last
year
and then talk about how to proceed from
here but i assure you
i know some of captain this is in good
faith it's a genuine effort i think we
get there
uh and uh i'm hoping that uh just in
case
i brought along two of the secretaries
who are smarter than i am
so they can answer the really tough
questions but all kidding aside
i'm looking forward to this meeting and
i want to thank you all for coming in
and
we appreciate you being here so thank
you for being
[Music]
go thank here thank you guys thank you
thank you thank you let's go thank you